but Wisconsin decision is part of an
increasingly partisan fight on safety
and the economy nationally a majority of
the country believes the top priority
should be staying at home over getting
back to work but look at the party
breakdown 62% of Republicans say opening
the economy should be the priority
Democrats meanwhile overwhelmingly
support stay at home policies our lead
national correspondent David Begnaud
joins us now David what's the take away
from that decision in Wisconsin Anthony
it's a major win for Republicans who
control the legislature they convinced
the court and the court ruled that the
governor stay-at-home order was
unenforceable and invalid now the
governor of wisconsin who's a Democrat
fired back saying the Republicans have
no plan and they have essentially thrown
the state into chaos because now with no
state plan in effect effectively local
counties are gonna have to figure out
what to do here's a snapshot of what
else is happening around the country
shop in Owosso Michigan customers were
still getting their trims on Wednesday
the same day his license was suspended
for operating in defiance of the
statewide stay at home order they tried
to take my living away from me they take
my my craft away from me
that's vindictive in southern Illinois
Madison County local officials allow
some businesses to reopen with limits
including restaurants and gyms but cases
around the county are still increasing
and Illinois has not yet lifted
restrictions on those businesses
statewide Illinois Governor JB Pritzker
what I don't have sympathy for is those
so intent on disregarding science and
logic you weren't elected to do what's
easy you were elected to do what's right
to Texas now the Attorney General Ken
Paxton issued three letters to city
officials in San Antonio Austin and
Dallas threatening legal action against
them if local officials continue to
enforce orders that he calls
unconstitutional like mandating face
masks in public and continuing stay at
home orders the fact is our orders have
been in compliance with the governor
from day one as local governments work
to balance Public Health and economic
concerns questions are being raised
about reopening schools something
President Trump says he favors I don't
consider a country coming back if the
schools are closed and very little
impact on young people you know health
experts are still learning more about
that new disease and children which is
potentially linked to the corona virus
he got to keep anything down and belly
pain on May the 3rd Amber Dean's
nine-year-old son Bobby fell ill with
pediatric multi-system inflammatory
syndrome he went to the emergency room
the next day and later tested positive
for the corona virus amber says his
heart was beating abnormally fast and
his fever was as high as 102 degrees
what was the scariest part for you just
hearing that his heart was that bad last
thing I want to do is have my
nine-year-old have a heart attack
Bobby wound up in the pediatric
intensive care unit but after four days
he started to improve it's a hard thing
the best they can but they're not used
to dealing with it so it's kind of scary
you know amber Dean says she and her
sister who had been living in the Dean
home both had coronavirus and they can
only assume that's where the young boy
contracted it there are at least a
hundred and eighty cases of this disease
in 17 states around the country and
Washington DC Gail as of this morning at
least three kids have died from this
David thank you very much